I'm not listening to what she says I'm
watching what she's
doing and men don't get that the average
man doesn't get that that's why I should
join the
world not because we're sitting there
talking about about bad about women I'll
tell you a group in the war room that I
think is very impactful in a way it's
called relationships with loving loving
relationships with women it was
something along that it's a very kind
room just helping guys find the right
frame it's not talking badly about women
like the like the media talks about
Andrew it's like Hey listen if you
really really love her you're going to
have this Frame because this Frame is
going to allow you to keep the
relationship going for a very long time
that's the beautiful thing